[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous parle d'un temps que les moins
de vingt ans ne peuvent pas connaître
paris en ce temps là c'est amusant
d'évoquer cette belle chanson de charles
aznavour et pourtant c'est vrai
transportons-nous 35 ans en arrière dans
un monde sans téléphone portable sans
ordinateur sans internet sans gps sans
réseaux sociaux sans gaf a je m'appelle
catherine fef 1985
j'ai 30 ans je suis journaliste artiste
peintre et je circule à paris en vélo
solex
oui ce drôle d'engin avec un moteur à
galets sous le guidon est brusquement
coupe-faim dérapages arrêt avec les
pieds je revois très bien la scène un
étrange individu emballe le pont neuf
avec une immense toile
ces cristaux il arrive tout droit de
bulgarie il faut être sacrément
téméraire et visionnaire pour concevoir
un truc pareil
une avalanche de questions me vient à
l'esprit mais comment at il obtenu
l'autorisation de la mairie de paris
comment at il fait pour convaincre son
équipe de s'engager dans cette mission
impossible mais surtout la question qui
me trotte dans la tête depuis ce temps
là c'est comment faire vivre l'art le
grand le beau dans la ville aujourd'hui
je vais vous démontrer l'intérêt de
communiquer en grand format mais aussi
comment décupler ses forces
lorsqu'on n'est pas plus grand que ce
timbre poste que je tiens entre les
doigts je suis d'accord avec vous on ne
voit pas grand chose
j'ai mieux
voici maintenant une carte postale on
voit un peu mieux mais ce n'est pas
encore très convaincant vous clignez des
yeux pour deviner ce que c'est voilà
maintenant une affiche alors là vous des
chiffres est bien le visuel c'est un
chat voyez vous je veux en venir
peut-être pas regardez bien
alors là c'est l'effet waouh où les
faits miaou comme vous voudrez l'image
prend toute sa force toute sa puissance
on ne peut pas y échapper c'est ça la
communication en grand format
de 1985 à 1986 l'administration de
cristaux a fait son chemin dans ma
petite tête et je me répète souvent un
coeur vaillant rien d'impossible
bien convaincus qu'avec peu de moyens on
peut quand même réaliser de grandes
choses il faut croire en sa bonne étoile
et se forcer à rester résolument
optimiste car l'échec n'est pas une
option
avez vous déjà eu l'impression que la
vie vous envoyer des signaux inévitable
sur votre chemin
et bien c'est ce qui m'est arrivé ce
jour là je vois dans une rue bien
commerçante
un chantier de ravalement vraiment très
mal tenu des lambeaux de bâches usagers
pendouille de ci de là et tout à coup
une petite étincelle jaillit dans mon
esprit vous savez comme dans les bandes
dessinées les échafaudages bon sang mais
c'est bien sûr une toile d'échafaudages
qui serait bien propre et bien entendu
c'est exactement comme une feuille de
papier géante
je viens de faire une découverte qui va
changer le cours de ma vie c'est alors
que j'ai pris mon courage à deux mains
tout en oubliant d'avoir peur
d'ailleurs c'est vrai la peur n'évite
pas le danger il faut la remplacer par
une certaine inconscience et se laisser
guider par son instinct de survie qui
vous permettra d'éviter les écueils
mais revenons à nos moutons
[Musique]
quelque temps après cette révélation
je tente une première expérience au coin
de la rue de lisbonne surgit un beau
matin un immense portrait peint à la
main
1800 m² de surface coup de théâtre
tel est le nom de cette bâche la bien
nommée
le décor est composé d'une centaine de
toiles de 18 mètres carrés chacune elles
sont posées les unes à côté des autres
à la façon d'un puzzle un chantier que
j'ai réalisé avec les moyens de l'époque
une usine désaffectée en guise
d'ateliers quelques pots de peinture
offert par un fabricant généreux des
toiles de chantier récupérer de l'huile
de coude
le concours d'une douzaine d'artistes
peintres engagé au pied levé et le
soutien moral et logistique de mon
compagnon
l'effet est immédiat
monumental l'image interpelle c'est un
succès la presse en parle
un nouveau médium est né car l'idée des
bâches peintes va faire le tour du monde
quelque temps après cette belle aventure
un nouveau défi se présente on va
restaurer l'arc de triomphe
il va y avoir des échafaudages et des
filets de protection sur plusieurs
milliers de mètres carrés
c'est le sujet qu'on ne peut pas laisser
passer mais qui pèse de tout son poids
et vous met une pression énorme que
faire comment le faire et comment faire
vite car les travaux de restauration
commence tout de suite il me faut
trouver une idée simple car les mailles
défi
les ne permettent pas de dessin précis
le sujet doit respecter l'histoire
l' architecture du monument et la tombe
du soldat inconnu
les spectateurs quel que soit leur âge
ou leur nationalité doivent comprendre
le message rien mais alors rien ne me
vient à l'esprit quand c'est comme ça il
faut prendre du recul
respirer et ne pas paniquer quelques
jours passent
en feuilletant négligemment un magazine
je tombe sur les trois couleurs du
drapeau français bleu blanc rouge
mon idée est là elle ne tient qu'à un
fil
vite vite je cours chez l'architecte en
charge de l'arc de triomphe
il est enthousiaste hockey me dit il on
y va il me reste à surmonter mes
appréhensions pas d'état d'âme me dis-je
je dois transformer mes craintes en
énergie positive et me forger un mental
d'acier et c'est comme ça qu'on a peint
au pistolet dans un terrain vague de
meudon 8000 m² de filet alors là je peux
vous dire que ça donne une sorte de
vertige à l'envers quand on voit se
dérouler sous ses yeux sur 50 mètres de
hauteur les filets pain je me demande ce
que je suis en train de faire et en plus
de ça les gens me regardent bizarrement
interrogatif voire inquiets c'est là
qu'il faut par être sûr de soi car le
doute est contagieux et puis plus tard
c'est le 14 juillet les troupes à pied
le défilé aérien et même le tour de
france
chaque événement semble parfaitement
s'associer à cette vision éphémère du
monument je respire enfin
l'histoire continue un samedi matin
en 1992 alors que je travaille seul à
mon bureau le téléphone sonne
un monsieur que je ne connais pas me
raconte l'histoire d'un château disparu
à berlin en 1950
j'ai un peu de mal à suivre surtout en
anglais mais bon je m'accroche
il veut que je représente en
trompe-l'oeil taille réelle le château
tel qu'il était avant sa disparition ça
représente quand même dix mille mètres
carrés de surface l'équivalent de huit
piscines olympiques
vous pouvez le peindre en deux mois me
dit il ne voulant pas perdre la face je
m'entends lui répondre ok no problem
haye can do it
je devine que mon interlocuteur à
sensible à mon assurance en partie
feinte donné l'impression d'être sûr de
soi ça rassure tout le monde moi y
compris
quelques jours après cette étrange appel
je trouve dans ma boîte aux lettres
d'anciennes photos du château et
quelques vieux plans d'architecte
je commence à travailler sur le sujet je
voulais donner l'illusion du palais avec
seulement trois couleurs elles étaient
étaient représentés les ombres portées
des reliefs du château mon client est
sceptique
il me dit alors voulez-vous présenté à
berlin un échantillon de votre projet
nous pourrons le suspendre à
l'emplacement du château pour voir si ça
fonctionne avec mon équipe je commence à
travailler sur un grand échantillon sur
une grande toile de 70 m² une fois sèche
est pliée dans une malle celle ci
faisait quand même 70 kg et me voilà en
route vers berlin
accompagné de ma très lourdes valises on
suspend provisoirement l'échantillon
quelques de suspense j'attends la
réaction de mon client
ouf il adore que la toile est ramené au
sol
mon interlocuteur sort de sa poche des
ciseaux il saisit ma toile et commence à
la coupée en deux sur toute la longueur
je m'interroge du regard et c'est de le
stopper
il me dit alors il y aura un morceau
pour vous et un morceau pour moi de
retour à paris vous peindre et les dix
mille mètres carrés avec la même
précision et les mêmes couleurs je garde
ce morceau témoins pour vérifier votre
réalisation
je pense en moi même on n'est pas là
pour rigoler à ce que je vois et c'est
ainsi que je fis la connaissance de
berlin eh bien figurez-vous qu'on l'a
fait
les dix mille mètres carrés ont été
peints à issy les moulineaux puis
transportés en camion à l'emplacement du
château le trompe-l'oeil fut très
appréciée des berlinois le plus
incroyable de l'histoire c'est qu'après
une dizaine d'années de vives polémiques
l'idée de la reconstruction du château
on dure fut finalement adopté par le
gouvernement en 2002 et maintenant le
château est en cours d'achèvement a donc
fallu presque trente ans pour en être
témoin
je n'aurais jamais cru à l'époque qu'un
tel défi soit possible
l'histoire n'est pas terminée maintenant
c'est au tour du château de saint-cloud
disparu depuis 150 ans il fait
actuellement beaucoup parler de lui nous
sommes une petite équipe de joyeux
téméraires nous essayons de convaincre
le ministère de la culture pour réaliser
un immense trompe l'oeil du château dans
l'écrin du parc de saint cloud sur son
belvédère qui surplombe paris plus
personne ne s'imagine exactement comment
ils étaient moi non plus pour tout vous
dire
mais cette idée me met en joie et
finalement c'est ça qui compte
ce que je voudrais vraiment vous dire
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il faut avoir
confiance en soi
faites comme moi n'ayez peur de rien
voyez grands voiliers grand format vous
verrez mieux l'objet
tif à atteindre le monde de demain est à
portée de main merci de votre attention
est vive
l'imagination
[Applaudissements]